geplant war das ganze so nicht doch die
raumsonde berschick hat für die ersten
mond bewohner gesorgt einige tausend
bärtierchen die israelische
raumfahrtmissionen war im april schief
gegangen und die sonde zerschellte
anschlag planmäßig zu landen an bord
äußerst robuste überlebenskünstler die
bereits einige aufenthalt im weltall gut
überstanden haben wimmelt es auf dem
mond also jetzt vor bergkirchen
wahrscheinlich schon aber in einem sehr
seltsamen zustand klicks und science
fiction hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's und vielen dank
für diesen super spannenden leben
vorschlag der aus unserer coolen
telegramm community von morpheus stand
die telegramm community findet er hier
nie darunter demi und in der video
beschreibung sie haben acht beine und
ihre form erinnert an gummibärchen doch
sie haben quasi superkräfte egal ob
radioaktiver unfall gigantische chemie
katastrophe oder die komplette
austrocknung der erde die bärtierchen
würden das alles überstehen sie sind
wahre überlebenskünstler und das liegt
an einem speziellen schutz mechanismus
an ihren genen und all das könnte ihnen
jetzt zugute kommen denn einige tausend
dieser überlebenskünstler befinden sich
wohl seit dem elften april auf dem mond
dorthin gekommen waren sie an bord des
israelischen raumfahrzeuges verschied
das laut plan eigentlich auf dem mond
landen sollte also landen
sieben wochen lang war die sonde
unterwegs doch beim landemanöver fiel
der wichtigste motor aus und das in den
letzten minuten das raumschiff
zerschellte aus der israelische traum
als vor der nationen auf dem mond zu
landen
doch die passagiere an bord auch bekannt
als wasser bären haben
höchstwahrscheinlich überlebt da sind
sich fachleute eigentlich ziemlich
sicher denn sie kommen nicht nur ganz
ohne sauerstoff aus sondern können
sowohl vakuum als auch extreme kälte gut
überstehen
in der fachsprache ist von einer
sogenannten kryptologischen anto des
ähnlichen zustand bei dem die tierchen
ihre stoffwechselaktivität
herunterfahren und so extremen
umweltbedingungen trotzen
ein forschungsteam der universität
stuttgart hatte einige brt ich ihn vor
mehr als zehn jahren mit einer
russischen rakete ins all geschickt die
lebewesen
zehn tage dort einige von ihnen ließen
sich ohne probleme wieder beleben doch
wie kann das sein dazu ein forscher von
der universität tokio
paktika zu tun sie können einfach so
zwischen leben und seiner tod hin und
her wechseln das ist unglaublich
er war dem geheimnis der bärtierchen im
jahr 2017 auf die schliche gekommen eine
schutzhülle rund um das erbgut der
lebewesen fängt alle schädlichen
einflüsse ab konkret handelt es sich um
ein protein das das erbgut vor schäden
bewahrt in der fachsprache genannt
vorstellen kann man sich tatsächlich
dass wir eine art superhelden cape an
der dna befestigt es sich durch
elektrische anziehung aber das eben nur
an der einen seite an der anderen seite
flattert ist locker herum und sorgt so
für den schutz das haben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
bei den strahlungs tolerantesten aller
bisher bekannten bärtchen dem
sogenannten ramazzottis variieren natus
herausfinden können zurück zu dem
bärtchen die jetzt auf dem mond leben
sie waren tatsächlich teil einer art
bibliothek die stiftung art mission hat
sich zum ziel gesetzt wichtige infos
über die menschheit als eine art
sicherungskopie der erde im weltall zu
hinterlassen ganz vorne mit dabei
der unternehmer nova spiewak er hatte in
der vergangenheit in quarz gravierte
bücher ins all geschickt und zwar im
handschuhfach eines tesla roadsters
däninnen maske im vergangenen jahr 2018
als werbegag in den weltraum geschossen
hatte doch auch bei der israelische
mission hatte nova spiewak seine finger
im spiel hatte dazu nicht nur die
bärtierchen als überlebenskünstler
ausgewählt sondern auch tausende werke
der weltliteratur
diese hatte er auf michael scheiben
gravieren lassen mit an bord der sonde
waren auch dna proben von 25 menschen
und spuren von exotischen pflanzen
spielberg ist sich sicher dass die
bärtierchen die explosion und den
absturz auf dem mond gut überstanden
haben
wir glauben dass die überlebenschancen
der bärtierchen äußerst hoch sind er
hofft dass die sonne die bibliothek beim
einschlag ausgeworfen hat und sich diese
nun in der nähe der absturzstelle
befindet doch die lebewesen befinden
sich ja in einem getrockneten zustand
vor ihrer großen reise hatte man sie in
einen ruhezustand versetzt indem man
ihnen wasser entzogen hatte
sie gehen dann
die sogenannte tönchen phase über und
aus dem märchen werden eben tönchen in
diesem zustand überleben sie nahezu eben
alles die bedingungen auf dem mond sind
allerdings als ungeeignet für eine
reanimierung denn nun wieder aktiv zu
werden zu wachsen und sich zu vermehren
brauchen sie nahrung sauerstoff und
wasser werden und ihre edlen dna hammer
video mit noch mehr infos anklicken
anschauen und weltraum wissen von aston
comics tv abonnieren
sehr sehr cooler kanal bis dann bleibt
dran